all right little mama yes sir mama what
so it's been about a year maybe a little
over a year since you were here last
yeah tell me what's going on in your
life
so what's going on is
um i let master jay back into my life
you know he's a person too
you know and i love him a lot you know
and he loves me it's just that
he he needs some help
[Music]
let's start over
mark wants to start over okay
all right little mama yes sir well mama
welcome back
thank you it's been a little over a year
since you were here last and tell me
what's going on
in your life since then
well what's going on in my life is
i'm making plans to get myself together
and the reason why i say this is
because i let master jay back into my
life
um i love him and
he loves me and
it's just that i think he i think he
needs some help
i think he needs
to be touched i don't know
what do you mean by touched um
i don't know i mean i i guess he needs
the right person to come along and talk
to him and
you know just you know you know how you
grab a person and you
make them shoot the [ __ ] with you you
know what i mean
like i don't know
help them see things differently yeah
don't
wake up a little bit yeah it could be
you guys have been together for how long
on and off um
totally like we're like three
to four years you know
i see you have a black eye yeah
so i got to tell you the story with this
one
so we have a friend named john that has
a silver mercedes
and when we see john we get very happy
because
we know he's got like a few hundred
dollars that he's gonna you know
help us out with whatever you know for
food
cigarettes you know hanging out so
we sent him to do something for us to
get some weed for us
and when we sent him
we were there and we pulled off so john
goes well
you know little mama i want to kick you
with you you know what i'm saying
so i was like okay so this guy takes me
buys me an outfit you know buys me some
toiletries
um so i could get cleaned up real nice
at the time
and uh
you know we're buying different little
things drinks and driving around and
stuff like that
so we're in gardena so at the time he
has to go to
like bellflower norwalk to get his bank
card
so we go out there he gets his bank card
he gives me money you know buy me some
you know like i'm saying
you know just take care of me basically
so
i get a hotel room for master jay and i
because we live in a camper and
um you know i'm getting ready to tell
him
everything that i've done and because
it's been more than two or three
two to three hours i get sucked in the
face
and it's just like are you serious like
i'm
trying to get something done for us
for us yeah i mean there's so many
different ways this lifestyle is played
out
amongst a man and a woman i've learned
yeah and some of the some of the men
can't handle
a woman who's trying to support them
in the ways that you guys do and other
guys get it
and some women are meant for this
lifestyle and other ones just
aren't cut out for it and they're doing
it to support a drug habit or they're
doing
it to support their kids but other women
are doing it because they just
they love it they love it wow i don't
know so much about
loving you know um i just
i mean i just know i love the person
that i'm with you know
and i know that we have to survive
you know what i mean and i just that's
why i'm saying that he needs help
because he do you know
now this like i said this has been a
week and
we pretty much you know got right back
together
so we've been together for a while but
um you know so recently i'm hearing
about
a job you know i'm just saying some of
the things
you know recently i'm hearing about
working recently i'm hearing about
you know let's go somewhere else to a
different a job for who
for him yeah i'm hearing about yeah and
um you know let's let's you know
because i what happened with he's not
really a pimp is he or is he
you know what now he had he does have
other i've seen
you know we've been getting into it a
lot or going through it a lot because of
him and other women
you know so i don't know what's going on
with that maybe that's his ways of
getting the money he has you know what i
mean
um i just know that now we're talking
about like
making some changes and you know
um getting an rv and like going
somewhere else going
live in a total different environment
where we don't maybe know
you know where anything we indulge in
that's
harmful is you know yeah different
environment
yeah you know maybe go and check out uh
what's up north like the state of
washington is up north
from california there's so many places
so i'm just saying like just going
somewhere where
we don't know to do those things you
know i mean
we just know to do normal stuff yeah you
know
healthier environment perhaps i'm just
saying i'm recently this is
recently very recently so
i don't know if it's the threat to like
just totally leave or what
you know you've been hit before
have you been hit before yeah yeah
and he's not the first one i don't know
what it is like i said if this
relationship doesn't work out between
him and i
um you'll find another guy to hit you
no i'm good because i've seen that
before i
am going to get me together
i'm not worried about being in the
relationship no more
or none of that i don't care how lonely
i get or none of that
i gotta get me together and once i get
me together then i can date whoever i
want
but i'm just i'm just yeah you could i
mean
if you take care of yourself yeah he'll
either follow your lead or
be left behind and that's his problem
not yours yeah because
you you'll have taken care of yourself
yeah mark so
there's so much you're still young
there's so many things you can do with
your life
i'm trying i just
it's hard for me to leave someone it's
hard for me to
just leave someone hanging yeah i get it
i mean a lot of commenters
that watch these videos your videos will
will say oh
leave leave the dead beat or the abusive
guy
and they have to remember what if it's
them or you know
maybe they're not near right on that
level but let's say
if it is them in any type of way i
wouldn't walk away from them either you
know what i mean
would they want would they want me to
walk away from them if it was them
there's a million different types of
relationships i've learned yeah and just
because
what you have doesn't
fit what somebody else thinks you should
have doesn't match what
someone else thinks you should have
doesn't mean it's not right for you
right you know maybe he's the right guy
for you maybe he
i'm not saying i'm not saying hitting
anybody is cool right but
i i understand yeah it's just
i don't know love is crazy yeah
but i think taking care of yourself is
is the wise thing to do
yeah it's about getting me together i
already told him like a day or two ago i
said hey i'm gonna um
i'm gonna call your family and tell him
to come get you because he has family
that lives
in other states and he needs to do
something different
but i know when he go to that vegas oh
he does the same
thing over again so
[Music]
are drugs still in the picture for you
a little bit yeah see that that's that's
going to be a
snag no matter what yeah um i gotta
it's time for me to get clean and sober
you know and i'm not i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna lie to you
and when you ask me that question
because for me it's
important for people to know so they can
understand where you're still
at you know what i mean like
like that mark so i basically know that
i need to do something totally different
you know one thing i've learned through
doing all these talks with
with people like yourself and from other
walks of life is
is if you do the work yourself rather
than
somebody like giving you a
and all that if you do it yourself you
build
the self-worth and the
the feeling that you deserve the
rewards for changing your life and and
it
becomes more permanent whereas if i if i
stepped in and gave you some money and a
place to live and
a car and whatever else and found you a
job and all that stuff
it's much more likely that things go
haywire yeah that i see
i've seen it happen many times yeah but
if you build it by yourself and
maybe i help you here and there but
basically you did the work yourself
that becomes so much more permanent why
why yeah i love the way you're thinking
yeah thank you
[Music]
so your kids do you see them or you talk
to them
oh they're doing good they're doing good
yeah
they're doing real good the girls are
growing man
so that's another reason i mean that's
well that's the very reason for me i
mean i know it's supposed to be for me
you know through god or whatever but
like i look forward to
bringing him a whole bunch of barbie
[ __ ] like i said
yeah but for my my attitude on all this
kind of stuff is
if you do it for yourself your kids will
see that and they'll follow suit
yeah whereas if you do it for them and
you still suffer
the kids will see you and that's kind of
what's going on right now
so yeah you need to take care of number
one yeah and your kids will
your kids will be fine if you do ace for
me all right
it'll be for me that's great well mama
thank you so much for coming back
and i love hearing you talk sense like
this it's great
it's probably time for a change right
yeah
so it's it's like after the fourth of
july
our next holidays what halloween
so i figured i figured i'll dress
for halloween and
for thanksgiving and christmas i won't
get a donated plate i'll be in a program
one that we get to cook ourselves oh
really
good for you all right little mama thank
you so much
good luck great seeing you again
you